It's no secret that humans are the most
dominant species without proof of life
anywhere else in the universe.
We can probably consider ourselves the
most dominant species in space too.
But what if there were others just
like us millions of years ago?
How do we even know that we're the
first advanced civilization to call the
planet Earth Home?
And if there have been others,
what kind of traces of they left for us
to find this is what f and here's what
would happen if an advanced civilization
had already existed on earth.
We know that complex life has existed
on earth for about 400 million years,
but how can we look that far back?
Ancient Ruins and artifacts only
take us back a few thousand years.
Geologic records only about 2 million.
So if we can't rely on direct evidence,
then where else could we find traces
of a potentially extinct civilization?
And what can we learn to make
sure we avoid the same fate?
Okay,
here's some numbers to make
your brain hurt for a second.
The Universe is about
13.8 billion years old.
The earth is four and a
half billion years old,
and humans have only developed
our industrial civilization
in the last 300 years.
With all that in mind,
it seems like there was ample opportunity
for another advanced civilization to
emerge, flourish and Di all
before we even showed up,
but finding any proof of a past civilized
species seems like it could be harder
than even starting this
civilization itself.
Physical artifacts would be
the most concrete evidence
of past intelligent life,
but it's not very likely that
we'll ever find any. Over time,
even our tallest buildings will crumble
and our strongest materials will
disintegrate. Our city's cover less
than 1% of the earth's surface,
so any comparable cities from past
civilizations would be easy for
paleontologists to miss,
even if we knew where to look.
It's unlikely that these artifacts
would last any longer than a few million
years. Sure, there's always fossilization,
but it only provides a limited record
of the past due to variables like when
they lived and where an industrial
civilization that lasted 100,000 years,
that's over 300 times longer than us.
They might leave no fossil trace at all,
so maybe we're better off looking
for more indirect evidence.
The best way to find that would be to
look at what traces our own civilization
would leave behind if it
collapsed in its current state.
One place we're leaving a clear trail
is in the sediment to the bottom of our
bodies of water.
One look at this stuff and
you would immediately see
the wacky chemical balances
that would imply some sort of
outside influence. For instance,
the nitrogen fertilizers that we use to
grow food or running off into our bodies
of water and producing low oxygen
dead zones that would be visible and
sedimentary layers.
On top of that,
we'll be leaving long lasting synthetic
molecules from radioactive fallout
steroids and all the plastic
we dump in the ocean. So yeah,
future species are going to have a
great impression of us in case we're not
embarrassed enough.
Our technological advances are changing
the environment which is brought on
widespread extinctions that would be
visible at fossil records. Ironically,
perhaps the most promising marker of an
advanced civilization could be one of
the very things that brought on its
downfall. When we burn fossil fuels,
we are releasing carbon back into the air.
Fossil fuels ultimately derived
from decayed plants and animals,
which contain a variety of carbon
that has a different atomic mass.
Then most carbon in our atmosphere.
When this kind is released,
it changes the molecular makeup of the
atmosphere and leaves a clear signal to
future scientists.
In a 2018 study,
scientists hypothesize that civilizations
could even have fossil fuel driven
life cycles. When fossil fuel
use leads to climate change,
the oxygen levels decrease in the ocean
and help create a breeding ground for
new fuels like oil and coal.
In this way,
a civilization and its demise might sell
the seed for new civilizations in the
future. In our search for
intelligent neighbors from the past,
we may never actually find any evidence,
but we can learn a lot about ourselves.
Analyzing our own longterm ecological
footprint can have practical benefits.
It helps us recognize where we can do
better to achieve a balance with our
planet so that we don't become the
forgotten civilization of tomorrow.
While it doesn't seem likely that
intelligent life was here before us,
that doesn't mean there wasn't any.
For All we know they were so advanced
they were able to clean up their mess as
they went.
The only verifiable way to check if
someone was here before us might be to rev
up a time machine and go see for yourself,
but that's a story for another.
What if.